hi there guys I'm new seat here with
another gamespot news update for you
bring the bells and batten down the
hatches we've got another delay although
this one we could kind of see coming
because it's dragon age keep if you're
not sure what dragon age keep is it's
not a fancy case to house your copy of
dragon age inquisition it's a companion
web experience where you set up the
world of the upcoming RPG just the way
you want it by picking story choices
from dragon age origins and dragon age 2
so basically it's a way to import your
save without really doing any of that
importing stuff which might be tricky
considering those new console things
that everyone's yammering about it was
announced last week that Inquisition
will be hitting its planned October 7
release date I will instead launch on
November eighteenth and while it didn't
give an exact release date they did
insist that it will still launch ahead
of Inquisition which you know makes a
lot of sense dragon age keep is
currently running in a closed beta to
get involved you can apply online at
dragon age keep calm according to
bioware applicants aren't picked on a
first-come first-served basis to ensure
that they get a selection of users with
varying levels of dragon age experience
from your low level majors to the
completionist and the serial romancers
Bioware want you so are you excited to
return to sadist are you already eyeing
up your party members enchantment let me
know in the comments for all the latest
gaming romances stay tuned to eat to
gamespot
you